hey everyone today we're investigating
generating some procedural biomes for
our worlds
specifically what we want to do is we
want to take our little planets that
have some noise height applied and all
of that stuff
and we want to divide the world up into
somewhat plausible
regions with different climates in other
words
we want to make them look like actual
living thriving planets
and what we got right now isn't much a
sad rocky little world with some random
textures applied
this really doesn't look like anything
at all just a big space rock
we'll start by looking at earth since
it's really the only reference we have
and specifically the different biomes
that are present on this planet
biomes being the kind of distinct
regional climates that we're all
familiar with
the arctic rainforest desert tundra
these are all examples of the varied
biomes that we have on this planet
and although there are different ways
that these are typically classified
there's one in particular whitaker's
that we'll take a much closer look at
the nice thing about this classification
is as wikipedia mentions
he kind of boiled all the biomes down to
two factors
precipitation and temperature it's not
perfect
but you can see that most of the major
climates are represented by this simple
graph and that reduces the complexity
really nicely
so the plan is at least roughly in order
to get biomes into our world
we'll define a couple of things we'll
define temperature values across the
planet somehow
likely just as a function of proximity
to the equator
and then we'll define moisture or
precipitation values across the planet
probably just completely randomly we
need to make this change in a couple
areas
first off in the worker that builds the
mesh we'll call out with a new function
called get temperature
which we'll go implement now so in
texture splatter
we'll add this get temperature function
and we'll do something insanely simple
just use the absolute value of the
normal at this position as the
temperature
and here we go here's the planet with
the temperature showing in all its glory
notice the falloff from the equator
towards the poles
so we've got the temperature varying
from hottest to coldest there
and we can break this up with a bit of
noise since this is pretty homogenous
and kind of boring
in the code what i'm doing is just
adding a little bit of noise onto the
calculation by sampling a second noise
function
this works out pretty well the noise was
pretty basic before and this kind of
breaks things up a bit
hopefully looking a little bit more
visually appealing later
there's still some problems though if we
zoom in a bit there's some obvious peaks
and mountains that realistically should
see some falloff in temperature
when you look at a picture of real
mountains it might be sunny and warm at
sea level
but it's not exactly a tropical paradise
at the top temperature tends to fall off
pretty quickly with height so we need to
do the same thing
so we'll introduce a kind of fudge
factor to the temperature where we'll
drop it off depending on the height
above
sea level it's not super scientific
i kind of had to play with the values to
get this to look decent
that looks a bit better we've got some
pretty obvious height falloff for
temperatures now
which at least seems right intuitively
nothing here is based on real actual
science
i want to visualize this a bit better so
maybe to improve the look to see the
temperatures a bit better we'll take
some inspiration from what is
very arguably the greatest movie of all
time or at least among the best
and so what i'm doing is defining some
colors from red to yellow to blue to
black
and that'll give us hopefully a better
visualization of the world
this looks pretty cool i've kind of
jacked up the height of things
so you can see that the peaks of
mountains are cold and now i'd say we're
kind of done with temperature
at least for now so let's move on to
precipitation
or moisture levels this is going to be
pretty basic
whereas temperature varied quite a bit
with different factors
moisture is just going to be a straight
up noise sampling with some height
attenuation
and that's pretty much it there's our
precipitation map on the world
so what will happen is that the areas
with lots of precipitation will be
lush jungles and stuff while we should
get deserts and that kind of thing in
dry arid areas
so with precipitation and temperature we
can pretty much do whatever we want at
this point
what i'll do is i'll go into the shader
and from here we can do a simplistic
copy of that whitaker biome chart
i'll define colors for high
precipitation areas and then for low
precipitation areas and use moisture to
blend between those
what you end up with is kind of neat
you've got an entire world at this point
but more importantly as i zoom around
down by
the equator here for example i've got
lush jungle zones
and desert zones it looks pretty
plausible
now as i pan up north i get more
temperate climates and eventually as i
get to the north pole it goes pretty
barren and snowy
so this is kind of working we can tweak
the coat a bit to add an
ocean and mountains as well or at least
some sort of coloring from space
we'll circle back at some point and make
a legit ocean shader but for now we've
got blue
it looks pretty decent when you're far
out i'm happy
it's not the best but what we're really
just going for is zones and so this is
kind of good enough
back in the code we can continue
tweaking and improving the look a bit
what i'm doing here is i'm adding a
quick and dirty foam lighting
calculation
since up until now we've just been
looking at this unlit
that gets us a bit further looking
slightly worldly
realistically we kind of finished what
we set out to do here which was
build some sort of way of
differentiating climates and biomes in
our procedural world
but i'm going to run with this a bit
more first thing i'm going to do is
reincorporate that tri-planar mapping
that we introduced a few tutorials back
if you recall in that tutorial we
explored tri-planar mapping and tiling
repetition
and we're just shoving that code back in
but i'm only enabling it for the normal
maps
i'm also adding a bit of extremely low
frequency noise to the normal map which
will show up when we're far from the
ground
and i dumped in some warped noise to the
ocean and i also changed the lighting
model to a quickie
physically based lighting model this is
the final result of kind of fiddling a
bit with the shader
this was just for fun i mean we already
did the biomes
but you can kind of see that with just a
few little additions to the shader here
and there we can go pretty far
and honestly this is just the start
researching this
there's so much more that you can do if
you want to have a hyper realistic world
you can go with actual simulations of
tectonic plate movement to figure out
mountain ranges
you can use proximity to oceans and
mountains to figure out rain patterns
better
do simulations of currents blah blah
blah blah the list goes on
we're really just breaking the ice here
on what's possible
personally i'll stop here unless i have
a compelling reason to go with way more
advanced stuff
this gives pretty good results already
so until next time
cheers